so I think in the in the 45 minutes or
so that we've been talking we've talked
a lot about their ideas and obviously
we're not fans of their ideas but I
think there's something more pernicious
going on here with some of the tactics
because I don't think it's a coincidence
that many of the main players in this
regressive left movement have been
exposed to be liars to be plagiarists to
be frauds to basically manipulate
people's words to create memes that are
knowingly misquoted all of these things
I don't think that's a coincidence now
you may disagree what with what Sargon
of Akkad says or what Dave Rubin says
but I don't think you would find
instances where we maliciously
misrepresented people and I suppose
they're just their argument if you
really got them alone if you could
really get an honest moment out of them
which I don't know you could get but I
suppose their argument would be well the
ends justify the means and that's just
the reverse of how I view the world yeah
now that says almost honestly that's
exactly what it is right it's about it
there there's a lot to unpack here
actually there's these people are being
primed in universities to be activists
and part of the priming is to give them
a good feeling about doing this activism
you know it's to make them think that
they can emotionally reward themselves
by saying yeah I argued with a
misogynist on Twitter you know
therefore oh yes oh no I'm not kidding
that that genuinely is I've seen
feminists I've seen you know pictures of
thumbless courses where on the wall they
have a big Twitter activism is feminism
and stuff like this and it's just like
really that's you know this is a thing
they're encouraged to be activists they
they're encouraged to emotionally reward
themselves for being activists so do you
know my theory about never argue with
the Twitter egg that's what I'm gonna
put on my tombstone one day yeah I I i
care about ideas and not like people or
numbers so I can when some would like
five followers says you're wrong in this
I've got to argue the case Wow I might
be a little more evolved than you that's
pretty good
I'm also saying that at the schools that
there's this there's an intellectual
incentive or there is a feeling
incentive there's an emotional incentive
and basically it's they've got to the
point where they've convinced themselves
that progressive or regressive ISM is
the only morally legitimate position to
hold and so anyone not holding this
position must be a bad person and that's
everything about progressivism
in a nutshell right there if you aren't
a regressive you are a bad person if you
aren't sacrificing other people's rights
for the rights of a group that you don't
know you've got no connection to but you
have been emotionally primed to fight
for then you're a bad person and so it's
okay for me to call you all these
terrible names I mean I you would have
to be pretty damn racist for me to call
you a racist you know it's a bad label
it's a ring it's a label with a lot of
weight and yet these people throw around
as if it means nothing you know you know
I always say that I think I said this to
you and I was on your show that my
awakening had a lot to do with that
whole ben affleck sam harris thing on
real time and and part of what the
craziness of was with that was that been
throughout racist so quickly that i
agree with you it would take a lot it
would take a lot there are obvious
racists out there and they should be
called out but if you were arguing with
someone it would take a real special
person for them to illuminate that they
were racist within 30 seconds i mean
yeah i can only imagine that they came
straight out of the gate with it or
something like yeah okay black people
should be under shipped off the cotton
plantations or something like it well
you're a racist then aren't you the
black well I don't call myself I
wouldn't but some you know yeah these
things normally hold a lot of weight and
they and that's the reason they use they
use labels as weapons and they don't for
a reason for a couple of reasons I see
the first one obviously to put you on
the back foot as soon as you're called a
racist or homophobic bigger or whatever
then you're defending yourself you're
not defending your ideas you're not
attacking their ideas you're defending
yourself as a person and that's in
itself a logical fallacy called an ad
hominem you know to attack the person
rather than the ideas and that you all
find that they do this a lot so
basically right the answer to this is to
just say in your opinion
and then so they'll say you're a racist
and you say well in your opinion right
they'll say you know you're a racist
you're a sexist tripping it's all in
your opinion you know I'm not and I know
I'm not and nothing that I've said would
make any reasonable people person think
that but you are not a reasonable person
and therefore you're going to label me
as a racist or big or whatever and
honestly what you've just given me is
your opinion it's not an objective
statement of fact it's like when they
use the word problematic they'll say oh
that's problematic I said well can you
explain to me what problematic means
right immoral does it mean wrong doesn't
mean illegal know it means transgressive
to progressivism or feminism and it's
basically the same as sinful in the
Catholic Church whereas the same Haram
in Islam you know it's it's the this is
transgressive to my ideology is not
listening wrong and it's not an
objective statement of fact it's I don't
like what you've done right so that I
love that because it goes to show that
they want a certain intellectual or
ideological purity and that's what the
church would want out of you or or any
sort of authoritarian view would want an
intellectual and ideological pure not
intellectual purely ideological purity
it's usually not that intellectual right
absolutely they want an ideological
ideological purity out of you and what
that does you know I'm seeing this right
now in our democratic debate last week
between Bernie and Hillary they were
arguing over who's the bigger
progressive and it's like guys that's
not what the fight should be about it
should be about if you're on the left it
should be about who is standing up for
liberal principles more not who fits
this narrow definition because guess
what then all you do is we've said a
zillion times as you hand the debate
over to the right and absolutely yet
Donald Trump the steering in their own
juices there as well no I'm the bigger
progression salute you you don't need to
you don't need to worry about convincing
people about who's the bigger
progressive progressives are going to
vote for you you know liberals right but
the people you want to convince are the
swing voters who aren't died in the you
know dime the more progressives then the
people who aren't you know who concerned
about issues and they said about
policies you know who can send out what
you're actually going to do rather than
you know ideological brownie points you
know that and so yeah it's just this
little circle jerk where they've stood
and their own ideology for so long
they don't understand how they're being
viewed from the outside and like you
said it's driving people to the right
you know it's absolutely driving people
so then what what do we do because that
is not us right we're the ones we're the
ones that are trying to defend classical
liberalism I'm sure you get tons of
emails and tweets and all that stuff
that I get all the time about I see this
split this has happened I get people
telling me they're afraid and and
embarrassed to call themselves on the
left I get other people saying they
won't post things on Facebook because
they don't want to get called a racist
so all these things so if there's this
growing group of people which there
absolutely is I have no doubt about it
what what do we do to keep this message
going okay um okay so the great thing
about what's happening is that need it's
interesting because I mean like I said
you had my lady innopolis on your show
he was a he was the only journalist who
was prepared to cover gamergate in Italy
and I've grown to become friends with
him and people find it really odd
because he's a conservative and I'm a
liberal and I just tried to explain them
a look right we've come to the point
where it's not really about political
affiliation - left and right it's about
whether we can agree on a reality you
know we can interpret this reality and
have our own opinions in any way I'm
sure he's got a lot of things that I
disagree with we can agree that the
numbers are such did the events are as
follows you know whereas the progressive
left will lie to you they will light
themselves like that like we said they
will cherry-pick their narrative they'll
choose several date points leave out the
ones that contradict what they've said
and then if you don't agree with their
narrative they consider you persona non
grata you're in urine you may as well be
you know Bill O'Reilly or something like
that
in their mind and just to be very clear
you're not just you're not just saying
something for the sake of saying it I
mean I have literally seen this happen
to me just to be very clear I mean this
is exactly what's happened to me which I
now wear as a badge of pride by the way
yes
well this is one of the things when you
first introduce people to this and they
don't know anything about it I honestly
think there is a lot of they protect
themselves with audacity and I mean I
I'm a big fan of military history and
audacity is one of those things that
wins many wars because it's so
unexpected and I really think
the things they do are so audacious that
it's hard to persuade people they're
genuinely doing them because people hear
it and think I would never do that right
do that you know I wouldn't do I can't
imagine anyone doing it that's not
happening you're a liar you know and
they think that the person relating the
information is the one telling the lie
and so the progressives I think you know
they really thing take up on this and
say well that's because he's a racist he
sexes and all these things and then the
person that has to experience them
acting as they act to read and I've had
so many people come out with a man I
thought you were full of nonsense when
when I first took but that was exactly
how they are
yeah mate I told you honestly don't
worry about it you know just know no
harm no foul something it's it happens
to everyone
because at first when you first hear it
sounds like nonsense you know you can't
believe anyone would act this way and
yet they do do you sometimes think that
maybe the best way to beat them at this
point is just to ignore them because I
think over the last six months between
what we do here what you do what many
other people are doing especially in the
digital space now and what Bill Maher is
done a little bit more in the mainstream
there's been and they've been exposed
and I think because as you said they're
stewing in their juices now part of me
is just like well let's just ignore them
and then you know then there's another
piece of me that says we have to keep on
the attack which do you think would be a
better lie low the origam is a very
dangerous tactic I think the the problem
the problem with that is that you have
the initiative to them and you say you
know I'm not gonna pay attention
excuse me for what you're doing and
therefore whatever it is they do a
you're not really aware of and suddenly
something will come at you that you're
not prepared for I and also it gives
them the ground to continue propagating
their ideological position yes that gets
them you know you there's no there's no
resistance and so I mean it's it on
Twitter yeah sure you know maybe maybe
there's a lot of resistance but like if
if you get a group a little delegation
of progressives who come to a workplace
and they say Oh we'd like to talk to you
about women's equality anything gone
then you know and so your boss might
like you know he's just a good guy he
doesn't know he's just oh right okay
well I'll do whatever I can you know
and suddenly these people are now
advising the upper echelons of this
company and then they start enforcing
ideological conformity and then suddenly
you're in this position where I mean
this happened to major game studios it's
happened to like games well at chop it's
there there are there are lots of people
who have fallen prey to the velvet glove
of social justice that contains within
at the iron fist yeah but it's really
well hidden so no I I don't think we can
just I I think we have to fight them and
we have to show people there is a better
alternative that's the eternal point you
have you've got to provide a better
alternative and universal liberal
principles in my opinion are the highest
alternative there there isn't anything
better you can't get anything more fair
than normal liberal principles so I I
honestly think just just pushing these
you know showing people these are the
best way to do things and that this not
only encourages equal treatment of
people under the law in any kind of
social situation but also it also pushes
people to be the best that they can be
it doesn't encourage them to be victims
it doesn't curse them to get you know to
be depressin to to milk it you know
there's no room for frauds when you come
to these sorts of meritocratic
principles people have to work they have
to push themselves and become better and
it's about raising the human condition
rather than dragging it down which is
everything about progressives yeah well
naturally I believe in what you're
saying and that's why I'm doing what I'm
doing yeah so I really more than
anything else I should thank you because
you know there were a couple key people
that helped my awakening and and when I
had that conversation with you on your
channel it was one of the first times
that I really started talking about this
stuff so you were definitely a key piece
in that so I appreciate that and I
appreciate all the work you do and
everyone can find out more of Sargon's
take on gamergate feminism regressives
and plenty more over on his youtube
channel which is youtube.com slash
sargon of akkad a hundred and sargon
karl or you have any other names that I
need to know about no I think that's
just the two those are the big two all
right well I appreciate it and thank you
guys for watching and we'll do it again
next week
[Music]